good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight Democrats have been
talking about impeachment since the very
day that Trump was inaugurated but until
recently no one here in Washington took
that idea very seriously Maxine Waters
would rant about a trial then Pilates
moms and Santa Monica would fantasize on
Twitter about removing Trump by force
but the adults in the party Nancy Pelosi
for example the Speaker opposed
impeachment on the grounds that it was
bad politics in might boomerang on them
and then in what seemed like a day
everything changed completely suddenly
we had impeachment hearings playing out
live on TV nobody explained why looking
back what exactly happened well part of
the answer is that Democrats were simply
responding to their own cheerleaders on
cable news
if precedent means anything in the Trump
ear Donald Trump will be must be
impeached but if they don't impeach
Democrats will abdicate a clear
constitutional chance to hold this
president fully accountable the national
nightmare is upon us the basic rules of
our democracy are under attack from the
president we begin tonight with a series
of admissions by the president that all
but assures his impeachment in the House
of Representatives I don't understand
why the fact that that impeachment is
polarizing is some sort it makes them
just as cowardly as they absolutely and
it to my mind it also is an application
of their constitutional responsibility
will there be any consequences for this
president who is continuing to defy the
rule of law of law here that mr. mrs.
America it's a national emergency and if
they don't impeach Democrats listen
carefully Democrats will abdicate their
solemn constitutional responsibility
Democrats literally have no choice but
to undo the 2016 election yeah that's
what the hair hats on TV the men who
wear makeup and yell at their assistants
we're telling Democratic leaders night
after night after night and remarkably
and it is remarkable looking back
Democrats believe the done so what
happened next
let's see have you read the new Vanity
Fair sorry rhetorical question nobody
reads Vanity Fair anymore it likely
won't exist
this time next year but before the title
disappears forever check out this
month's issue there's a fascinating
piece by Ken Stern that assesses new
polling on impeachment here's the
headline among independents the only
group that matters in an election
support for impeachment impeaching Trump
has dropped by 10 points since the
process started
how to explain this in political terms
this is the Andrea Doria a routine Cruz
that suddenly becomes a disaster a
debacle they spent two weeks telling you
that Donald Trump is a criminal and by
the end more people sympathize with
Donald Trump how'd that happen take a
closer look at the numbers and it's
obvious how it happened the independent
voters were asked to rank 11 issues in
order of their importance first on the
list was fiscal health seventy-four
percent of independent voters said that
the budget deficit was their main
concern 72% said health care was the
main concern 70% said infrastructure
pretty conventional impeachment that
came in dead last 11 out of 11 only 37
percent of independents thought it was a
priority at all by a margin of 3 to 1
and this is hilarious independent said
that impeachment was more important to
politicians and the media than it was to
them these are not subtle numbers so how
did Democrats miss them well because
they only talked to each other this is
what happens when you let Jeff Zucker
run your political party you start to
imagine that CNN's primetime lineup
somehow speaks for America rather than
for a tiny out-of-touch little part of
it sucker tells you that impeachment is
the only issue that matters
his eunuch agrees with them and you
believe them
come fall you lose the election in a
moment like this weirdly it's the non
politicians who seem to see things that
most clearly here's Andrew yang after
last week's politic presidential debate
but when I talk to voters around the
country wolf I have to say I get very
very few questions about impeachment I
know that there are people who are very
intent on the impeachment proceedings
day to day but that doesn't line up with
what I'm hearing from voters here on the
ground so what Democrats see you believe
be better off simply wrapping up this
impeachment process sooner rather
later I do think that the more time that
goes on the less time the Democrats have
to present a positive vision for the
country that would get people excited
and help us win in 2020 out in Santa
Monica the Pilates moms are looking at
that and saying Andrew yang did Hughes
criticize impeachment is he a right wing
or is he a racist is he telling us that
voters want politicians to care more
about their lives then they want
politicians to extract symbolic
televised revenge on their political
enemies if you watch Dennis NBC it's
hard to believe that could be true
but that's what the yang Guifei mning in
the wake of those poll numbers we just
read other Democrats appear to be
considering the same thing even Adam
Schiff may be coming around watch this
do you think President Trump should be
impeached I want to discuss this with my
constituents and my colleagues before I
make a final judgement on it and you've
also said that what you've seen is quote
far more serious than what Nixon did
explain to me how you have not come to
the conclusion that the president should
be impeached I mean it sounds like you
think he should be impeached well I
certainly think that the evidence that's
been produced overwhelmingly shows
serious misconduct by the president but
I do want to hear more from my
constituents and I want to hear more
from my colleagues this is not a
decision I will be making alone yeah
it's not gonna make the decision alone
just to make sure you got this clear the
man in charge of impeachment in the
house
the member you just watched for two full
weeks shepherding the impeachment
hearings the guy who cried on television
just thinking about how much Donald
Trump needed to be impeached right now
that guy isn't really sure he's for
impeachment you know he needs to talk to
his colleagues he needs to hear more
from his constituents it's a lot to
think about he's gonna prayerfully
consider it over the holiday weekend
just just alone just in some reflection
that's Adams chefs position now in other
words it's over Democrats lost